please welcome the host of the new
podcast
double date the legendary phil donahue
and marlo
thomas
thank you thank you i'm very nervous
i want six copies of that introduction
you got it hi marlo how are you
you forgot to mention that you visited
saint jude what a good girl you are
thank you thank you for having me it is
one of the most important hospitals
in the world and i mean it's hard to
pick
with both of you all the topics that we
want to talk about because you have
accomplished so many things and you've
changed the world
in so many ways so what we do here on
this show
is a timeline and so i thought if you
guys are open to it
we could do one with you guys we're here
for you babe whatever you want
okay great ready all right we're gonna
take a trip
down memory lane with a special edition
of
[Music]
it's called drew the year because we pun
my name with everything
um so going drew the years
in this beautiful timeline um i would
love to start with
1955. phil gets his first job
at a tv station and you started out
making one dollar
an hour erasing the blackboard for the
weatherman
and yet you still wanted to have a
career in television is any of this true
that is true that is true
i don't know if i'd have dated you if
you were making a dollar an hour
well how about erasing the blackboard i
mean that's
that was high tech oh i
love that yeah i went downhill from
there
all right well let's see where we're
heading to now in the drew the years
timeline
1962 saint jude's children's research
hospital
opens in memphis tennessee all because
of marlow's father danny thomas
what do you remember about this i can't
remember a time when he wasn't talking
about saint joe children's research
hospital about his his desire to build
it
you know and it was always in our lives
but
as i look back it seemed like a dream
that my dad had
not that was actually going to happen
but my father was
was the kind of guy who had a dream and
he made his dream come true
he drew the picture of the hospital on
one of those shirt cardboards
that come from the cleaners that was his
first drawing
imagine at our wedding he raised
he raised a glass and he said i haven't
lost a daughter
i've gained a fundraiser
so somewhere around the reception i
realized that i had married a hospital
and then that's what's kept us together
i mean you really have saint jude's is
heaven on earth
all right we're gonna head to 1966
that girl premieres on tv and marlo
plays
ann marie career-oriented woman and the
series is applauded for
its groundbreaking look at women's
independence
i mean were you ready for this
i was very excited to do it and i knew
it was going to be groundbreaking
because we had to fight so hard
to get it on the air the networks all
said that nobody would watch a girl who
wasn't a part of a family unit
but they had no idea that girls like me
that were in their 20s
were dying for somebody to tell them
that they could get out and be who they
wanted to be so
it was like every home in america had a
that girl in it
and then the producers and the network
and the sponsor clairol
all wanted uh the show to end with a
wedding
and i really had to say we can't do that
um
i just can't say that the only happy
ending is a wedding
all right next milestone 1967.
donahue premieres on tv
it changes the landscape it runs for 29
years
and you talked about so many
groundbreaking things that had never
been talked about on television before
were there times you were nervous
because it was so
unprecedented well
you know we're from dayton ohio not the
crossroads of america
and our first guest was madeline murray
o'hare
the most hated woman in america
she was the one who uh got the supreme
court to decree that
the reading of prayer in a public school
was unconstitutional well you know
madeline murray o'hare comes on our show
and she says
there's no god there's no heaven there's
no hell
when you die you go into the ground you
biodegrade and you become a part of the
physical universe
well the building fell in in dayton ohio
couldn't
people couldn't believe what they were
seeing
but boy did the rating the ratings were
as never before seen i i think
you really changed the world and when
you look at any history of television
it's you that were the first to
uh reveal what us human beings do have
an appetite for and are willing to go
there or want to be angry about it or
want to hate it or want to like it or
glad it's out there
you just brought everyone in we were
certainly different and
we had to be but i think i think that
was
your curiosity and what happened is
people
turned on his show to learn that that is
what i look for
today when i'm watching the news there
are certain people that we watch
on the news as we flip from channel to
channel and and
i think that that's what that's what
phil did i think that is so well said